the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so today I'm gonna sort of take a
more empirical approach and I feel like
I've done a lot of theory in this class
so today I'm gonna I'm gonna play
through the hands of an online attorney
so that I played and sort of show you
the most interesting hands and show me
exactly what I did I don't think I'm
gonna finish the whole journey today but
I'm gonna go through the first part and
I'm only going to talk about a few
little concepts but mostly just go
through them okay so it's it's a $55
buy-in tournament on Party Poker and
it's a fairly small field so this is a
tournament I played recently and okay so
so let's just get into the hands I'm
gonna show you the hands where I did
something at the start and we will start
with a bit of theory okay so this is
this is the situation it's folded to
this player and so we have king queen
here and it's a hand where were in
position and he raised from late enough
position where I think our hand is too
good to fold
so if dream if dreams crushed if the guy
who raised was from under the gun let's
say then then I might have I probably
would have folded because again sit
under the gun range came clean off see
it kind of gets crushed but against a
range from highjack -1 or low jack
I think King Queen is good enough to
play but the question is sort of what do
we do do we raise do we call I don't
think folding is the end of the world
you know I think it's slightly
profitable to play but it's not like
you're giving up a ton of equity by
folding this so what do we do okay so
I'm gonna start out with a bit of theory
so I haven't really talked about this so
this is so I'm gonna talk a bit a bit
about preflop me raising theory so in
this situation I don't want to just talk
about what to do with this hand right
this is how throughout this class I've
been saying we shouldn't think about
poker we should always think about the
general situation what's the range of
hands we could have what's the range of
hands they could have and how do how
should both players
their overall strategy with their entire
range of hands so okay so there's a few
interesting things to think about here
so there's sort of a dilemma so if we
think about our overall strategy
okay so first first thing you notice is
how many bets deep is it effective how
many what's the stack size effectively
it's about it's about 28 right I think
so yeah we have about the same amount of
chips we have like twenty eight and a
half big mines that's clear to everyone
so it's just one that it's fairly deep
here so the the stack size the effective
stack size is 28 and a half feet lines
and so what's the issue it's sometimes
in this spot we have a hand that's good
enough implied odds to play in position
but it's not really like a good hand
that we're trying to raise and make the
top figure with like an example this is
like King Jack suited or like King Queen
off I think is a good example too it's a
hand that's good enough to play but not
and that's good enough that we
necessarily want to raise and make the
pot bigger on the other hand sometimes
we have a hand that you want to raise I
hope you get along with like aces right
so we do have the we have these sort of
two types of hands that we want to play
in the situation but if we play
according to our hand it can become too
predictable right so so this is like a
somewhat intuitive strategy so you know
let's suppose this was our strategy
let's suppose our strategy was with the
best hands that we're hoping to get it
all and with let's say in this spot
pocket Tenon's plus an ace king I think
that's reasonable as as the set of hands
were willing to and happy to go all-in
with so pocket tens plus Ace King and
then we call with pocket fives plus ace
track off ace ten suited King Queen off
it says so so this I'd say this is a
reasonable strategy to play but what are
some problems with this sort of
intuitive exploitative strategy okay
yeah I'm good so yeah so that's a yeah
that's a good point so basically right
so people if we if we only raised with
pocket tens plus people can just fold
pretty easily
they know that we have a great handle on
every race good um okay what's another
issue this one's a bit more subtle
what's what sort of another issue right
so one issue is when we raise it's
obvious if you have a great hand and so
on a similar line another it should yes
right exactly okay okay yeah so this is
an almost bigger issue here is if we
play like this when we call people no we
can't have aces so you know one of the
guys behind like this guy I might just
be able to raise and build they're gonna
know we're gonna be fairly weak and
we're gonna have to fold most of the
time right so basically this is not a
really balanced strategy so what can we
do well we could raise some assortment
of hands from the call category to
balance it out we could call some hands
from the raise category to some small
percent of the time like play a
randomized strategy where you raise aces
eighty percent of the time and all aces
twenty percent of the time to balance it
out there's some other more extreme
things you can do that I don't think I'm
good in this situation but are
reasonable when the stack size is
different so I think if it's shallower
let's say only 20 big blinds deep then
just raising all hands just raising the
top X percent of hands is a decent
strategy because in 20 big blinds is
sort of shallow enough where if you
raise your kind of committing your whole
stack anyway and if it's deeper then
like if it's a hundred big lines deep
some players will like to call a hundred
percent of the hands they'll just never
raise I don't think it's like the
optimal strategy but it's not an
unreasonable strategy when if you're a
hundred big blinds deep and you have
position it's not terrible and then your
range is completely disguised because
you're playing all your hands the same
preflop so these are some reasonable
solution ideas so here's a sort of a
better solution so so here's so this
will sound really cool compared to the
previous slide which is instead of
raising some of the call hands as as a
bluff essentially to balance out the
times we raise is a good hand what if we
actually we bluff raise the best hands
that aren't good enough to
so let me just so we can look at this
again right so our strategy was we're
raising four value aka we're raising
hoping to get called with tens plus an
Ace King we're calling what's sort of
the pretty good hands like pocket fives
Plus ace Jack H 10 suited King clean off
and then we're gonna we're gonna Bluff
raised hands that aren't positive
expectancy to call so like pocket fours
H 10 off h 9 suited hands are even
weaker than the claw hands but in some
sense if we about if we Bluff raised
with these hands the benefit is we're
sort of not wasting them right like
let's say with these better hands like
let's say with ace jack-off I'm raising
my opponent goes away well I'm probably
gonna have to fold in this situation for
twenty eight and a half big blinds so
I'm sort of like wasted by ace jack
whereas you know if I did it with ace 10
instead then I get to call with my ace
Jack which I know is plenty to call and
not waste such a good hand Bluff raising
so this is a very important concept in
poker is called polarizing and in
general you know it's a sound strategy
right by just like wasting argument I'm
saying I'm talking about polarizing
sounds like a pretty reasonable strategy
right because it ensures that you're not
wasting your medium strength hands to to
bluff raise so so what's what's an issue
with it so it can be exploited if your
opponent um calls your three bet so so
does anyone actually see does anyone
actually see so let's say in this case
suppose this was my strategy so I'm
raising pocket tens plus and and Ace
King and I'm Bluff raising the hands I I
listed here against it okay I'll give
I'll give it $20 and gift certificate to
so like what's a specific board say
where someone can explain my strategy if
this was my specific strategy this is
just for illustration but like so so
look at my exact range and can someone
say sort of what's what's a very bad
flop for my range
yeah it flops high cards will be
thinking your range is generally high
cards but uh right so so if there's high
cards but we do have lots of aces and
kings right like if the flop comes like
like if there's an ace then it's pretty
good for our range right even though
they might be able to fold easily but
worse they're gonna win the pot but um
but what is like a specific what's the
specification yeah oh yeah so five six
seven is kind of bad for us right
because our range basically contains no
fives no six is no 7s but even five six
seven we still have like a bigger pair
quite often so what's like an even worse
case I hear that yeah hi plus draw or a
high-speed job straight drop yeah but we
can have those right we have these ten
suited in our range we have a king ten
suited in our range something like a
little pair yeah we don't have fours or
eights but you know on those boards like
pocket jacks even like ace king high is
a pretty good handed pocket jacks
there's there's something very specific
we're missing I mean this is just part
of this example but yeah right okay yeah
so that's sort of what I was I think um
you can get this now
essentially like so this suppose this
was our exact strategy if the board
comes queen-high then essentially they
know that we our range is pretty bad
because we don't ever have a queen and
we we I mean we could have kings or aces
but all of our other pairs are gonna be
smaller than Queen so I mean this is a
specific example but I'm saying
polarizing is in general a good concept
by this argument that they're not
wasting your good hands
but it can be exploited if your opponent
knows this specific way in which you're
polarizing and they just call your
rebate and see the flop and they'll be
able to play very well on the flop still
even if you have some good hands and
some blocks it can also be bad against
unpredictable opponents because by the
by the like East Jack East and our
let's say you three bet with each ten
instead of ace jack is an attempt to
polarize but let's say your opponent is
kind of bad and they might make a loose
call in the situation with ace 10 then
you you would have really hoped to have
a stack instead of H 10 if they're going
to call your raise of these 10 I mean if
you so if your polarizing you're sort of
assuming your opponent is gonna play
reasonably right so the point is the
reason why I don't want to sort of waste
ace Jack by brazing is because my
opponents probably going to fold a step
but what if they might call these 10
then I really would have wished I use I
rebates at least yeah so okay the short
answer is I'm not going to give a
conclusive formula on how to play this
situation because the short answer is
it's complicated and I don't think
anyone essentially knows what the
optimal strategy is yet but in practice
I think just raising the mix of hands
from the call category mostly the
offsuit hands which have more Sinn féin
odds is is pretty good as part of your
luck raising range and calling the best
hands from the radius category like aces
like trapping a small percent of the
time just calling aces maybe a fifth of
the time so that's sometimes you have it
when you call so that people can't just
really raise when you call and also
raise some of the best hands that aren't
plus CD to call so so polarize a bit
essentially the short answer is it's
complicated do you need to do a bit of
everything with all sorts of hands but I
just wanted to sort of talk about how
complicated this situation can be all
right so okay so let's get back to the
hand so what I decided to do here was
following the the thing I said about
re-raising with offsuit hands I decided
to so I decided to raise here to 555 and
so I think this is about the right
sizing because we're making it about 2.5
times his race and essentially we're
bluffing here and our hand is good
enough where it's not the end of the
world if they call because we have a lot
of chances to hit top pair and if we do
we're probably good because they're
probably going on with ace king aerys
queen preflop but essentially we're
bluffing
being he phones and and he does so we
take down the pot okay so so the very
next hand
I actually just noticed this during when
I was playing two hands so I didn't
notice this I didn't notice this during
the tournament actually but so what do
you notice it's actually we're actually
in these in the exact same situation
right but we have different cards so
it's good that you know we thought about
our overall strategy when we played that
hand because you will end up in the same
situation again with different cards so
okay so along the same lines so you know
but at the time you know I was probably
playing like 15 tables or more so I
wasn't really paying attention I
probably did I probably didn't remember
that irie raised my home at the hand
before but playing through this it
actually yielded a really good result
because what happened was they didn't
believe my three bet the second time
around and they went all in with you
know pocket sevens it's not a terrible
hand but definitely I think a weaker
hand and they were usually go on there
with but I guess they didn't believe my
rear ace after the previous hand so this
also sort of illustrates the importance
of like you said of sometimes having a
bad hand when we brace so that people
will do the actions when we do have a
good hands like pocket carrots okay so
okay so let's go on and so I'm only
playing through the hands that I that I
essentially played at this started the
tournament so so we doubled up the
starting Southwest 3000 we've got 6,000
now we get ace Queen we raise and we get
cold here and here this guy makes it so
this is a different player because we
eliminated the guy who used to sit here
and they make it 755 and I decide to
fold here I think ace queen offsuit is
just a bit too weak I think going all-in
is it wouldn't be terrible but I think
where when we raised from fairly early
position under the gun plus 1 and this
high Jack called they're not going to be
doing this as a bluff very often and
they're rebase to 755 I think usually
come
it's not guaranteed that they're going
they're going to go all and if we
there's they're gonna cost if we go
all-in but I think most likely they will
and they're gonna be ahead of urban age
so I decided fold it's a fairly tight
fold so does this guy
okay so I'm just going to continue
playing through my hands from the
tournament if if you have any questions
just stop me and ask okay so this is
sort of a weird hand and I actually
think I played this end quite terribly
so okay so this guy calls which I said
we should never do but I guess she
doesn't take my class okay so we get
Queen ten here we check we see a fob aha
so we flop a
two over cards a backdoor flush draw and
gather Street drum so I decided to lead
into it and so really lead my drawers
out hope he folds he calls and the
Turner's are free and then here so this
is where I sort of he decided to sucker
bet me so I talked about how you know he
shouldn't even be remiss if he doesn't
respect me because I mean in this case
it's you know it's not a completely
insignificant fraction of the pockets
like one-sixth so he is actually getting
some substantial came in into the pot
but it's still fairly small on the main
thing it does is it gives me an
opportunity to check raise but I'm not
going to I don't think I don't think
they're gonna fold off it enough there's
a lot of drawers they're gonna call me
with and I'm gonna have to bluff again
on the river so I decided to just call
which is reasonable so this is what I
think I played the hand poorly so the
river completes a lot of draws but
doesn't complete my hand and I just
check it down I just check it which at
the time I didn't lead out because I
thought you know the fact that I only
called the turn and suddenly decided to
bet big on the river would probably get
called but I think it's just not a
balanced way to play the hand because
plenty of times I will have clubs or you
know overall has John ten or something
I'll have a jack and I will want a bet
for value and here when I have a hand
that essentially has no chance of
winning the winning the hand it's
showdown like essentially I'm giving up
the pot for sure if I check because my
queen-high would never be good I should
definitely be bluffing so I didn't which
I regret
I let him take down the pot with her
please yeah I guess he kind of liked
that hand well he called eight three
suited and I guess he made money from me
because I didn't play very well from the
big money okay so the next hand we get
King Jack offsuit here we open probably
one of the weakest hands I'm opening
from this position I think probably in
my recommendations this is not in the
list they should open from hi jack minus
one but I decided to open because I'm
bored I guess okay so the flop is for
six floor with two hearts so I decided
to continuation back here I think it's a
fairly marginal spot I think just giving
up is okay I definitely wouldn't have
stab at the pot if I didn't have the if
I didn't have the King of Hearts but um
the fact that I have a backdoor pretty
good flush draw I decided to bet and
just hope that everyone folds and we did
get that which is which is pretty nice
okay so so you know our stack is
hovering around the same size we've won
some hands lots of hands it's still
relating the tournament the blinds have
gone up a bit but it's still far away
from the payouts okay so we get Queen
Jack on the button and and this guy just
goes all-in for a lot of Vettes
I mean it's I guess it's not that many
it's like 35 no sorry it's yeah it's
about 38 55 right so so I got hold here
obviously but I found a bit about like
his range and you know it's possible his
range is like entirely so I talked about
this in a previous class when do you
want to be going all-in for a huge size
it's essentially with hands that are
pretty good to get all in with preflop
but have terrible post flop implied odds
in this situation and what were the
hands that I listed there it's
essentially small pairs right like
pocket twos you really don't want to see
a flop it's it's quite a good hand
preflop but you really don't want to see
a flop because it's pretty much always
to be higher cards are going to
you're gonna be playing this guessing
game trying to guess whether your
opponent has a pair and the other type
of hand is like ace two offsuit where
once again you know you have an ace
preflop which is decent but you're just
going to be playing a guessing game on
most flops so you know it probably if I
had a very strong beat on him and if I
had like Jack ten suited here calling is
maybe not that bad because you were like
a coin flip against h2 off suit and
you're like a 54% favorite against
pocket threes so I mean I told it here
because my hand isn't suited and just
because there's a small chance they're
gonna have these Queen and my Meade was
nowhere near strong enough to get to
conclude that for sure
their range was only small here isn't a
six
okay so we lose a bit of chips we're
blinding down a bit here we get ten two
suited and so I called him the big
volume with four and a half to one odds
I think this is probably one of the
weakest hands I call I might not call
like a two suited although it's close I
mean you can make a case for calling
eight two suited so once again in my
odds my odds are really good by the
reverse implied odds deuce deuce or
really against me quite a bit since I'm
going to be out of position and I have
small cards what you'll usually make a
smaller pair than them but I decide to
call and we fought a flush draw which is
pretty good but I'm still gonna check
because this is a board more I'm just
gonna check to the preflop raiser and
like them continuation bet right so I
talked about leading in an earlier class
and I don't think this is a board where
we should leading we should be leading
and I think never leading is okay as
well so I decide to check and they check
back so we turn the flush which is great
and we bet 600 into 1080 so
unfortunately we don't give it any
action so we take it down okay so the
nest I think this is one orbit later so
under the gun raises small boy who is
very very short he only has seven and a
half big blinds call calls and we decide
to call with our seven with our
and a half to one odds here or 61 odds
so we flop Queen Jack five so we have
second pair with a backdoor straight
draw and a backdoor flush draw and the
smaller leg goes all in for 10:54 into
1380 so this is sort of I think a pretty
close spot I think if I knew for sure
that art in 1977 didn't have a hand here
I think calling is definitely fine we're
given about two point three to one odds
and I think second pair with these
backdoor draws is more than good enough
against his range but because I think
his range will mostly be drawers and top
hairs and second pairs probably not
bottom pair that often because they
didn't call preflop from the small blind
which I don't expect most players would
do with the hand like seven five suited
so you know we're not even that happy to
call him to be honest but I probably
would call but the fact that this guy
here is behind and they could raise or
they could call and we have to make more
decisions on future streets I think
really hurts us and I think we should
have folded it's fine I decided to call
so I don't know why but I don't think
this is a good place I think it's it's
just too risky essentially you know
it'll work most of the time and we and
because most of the time our tone will
fall because they're gonna see two
players putting money in but the times
where they do have something I'm gonna
have to fold and it's gonna suck so so
we do call they actually have the same
handed us so it worked out well I guess
we sort of like a bad because we could
have made a flush and they couldn't have
so we were technically ahead but we
gotta have two but yeah so yeah so I'm
not going through my tournament history
from from maybe one month to go and
saying I played every hand perfectly
when I look through here I definitely
there's a lot of there's a lot of
mistakes there's a lot of hands I wish I
could replay so okay so this hand I
guess is fairly simple so we have east
and I think it's definitely good enough
to get it all in here with so as far as
what my range is I think I think sorry
oh did you have yesterday I just thought
this guy's handle and I thought it was
fine okay now you have known ask me what
my handle means my handle is so I think
it stood for something I probably made
it when I was like 17 and I think it's
stood for something and I I might I
probably don't remember what it says
okay so okay so we go all in here so
this is sort of a no-brainer hand but
let's stop and think a bit about what
our ringing should be so I think with
Ace King ace king and pocket tens I
think it's fairly easy to get it on I
think with ace Queen suited I didn't get
it in I think if I had ace Queen offsuit
I would probably fold although with ace
Queen suited actually if this Jesse fund
guy had as many chips as us then maybe I
would have folded but the fact that
we're actually not risking our entire
6250 against the two players who are in
the pot is very relevant because I mean
armament covers us and they could in
theory pick up pocket aces but it's much
less likely for them to pick up pocket
aces then this jetski fund guy who's
already in the pot so the fact that they
only have less than 20 big blinds as
well helps our case a lot so I would
probably get it in with ace Queen suited
plus and then pocket pocket nines plus
probably is what I'd get it in with here
so we go all-in and we beat ace Jack
which is which is good yeah so I think
ace jack is slightly on the loose side I
mean I think it's a fine play definitely
to get it all in with ace Jack but maybe
they could have made it like it because
they
more than 20 big blinds here so I think
maybe they could have considered calling
or raising small and folding if someone
like us entered the pot but nonetheless
I think they played your hand fine okay
so the next thing we have pocket nines
so many this guy raises we call so we're
getting deeper now because we won the
last hand so now we've got we've got 40
big blinds and we call this guy also
calls and Liam kid goes all-in for 30
big blinds and so they get out of the
way I think this is actually a very
close spot so um I do think one big
incentive to get it all in this I think
it's not that likely that Liam kid has
like pocket kings or pocket aces because
I think there's a good chance they would
have just raised smaller maybe to try to
sector people in so I actually think I'm
not losing too much here and same with
article I think it's also very hard for
hardened do you have a good hand so even
though in the first example we talked
about how sometimes you know calling
with pocket aces here is a good play but
you know I said if one guy your buddies
that you're the second guy you should
maybe call with pocket aces like 20% of
the time when it's two guys here like
what is one guy who has released me who
has called and now you're deciding what
to do with populaces you know instead of
20% you should be calling it's literally
like you know maybe like 2% or 1% you
should be calling with pocket aces so
you know if you can by multiplying 1% by
the probability of getting belt pocket
aces which is around like 1 in 200 it's
literally like one other 20,000 PS
pocket aces here so so I'm not too
afraid of him so I really think getting
it in is fine but at the same time you
know I don't think I'm ever a favorite
here I think they're arranged
essentially like ace king ace Queen
maybe he's Jack suited and then
essentially pocket 10s pocket nines
pocket jacks pocket queens maybe
occasionally pocket eights so I could
have them an exact equity calculation on
poker so event if I did it probably
would've been very very close but I
decided if all and
okay so the next hand we get ace Jack we
may surrendered the guy this this guy go
this guy goes on for six big blinds
we're basically committed here even if
we think he's crushing us so I call and
we lose the ace king not really too much
we can do here although this does
illustrate one concept which is when
there are stats behind lines are busy
who are short enough that they can
commit you by going all-in
you should be slightly less incentivized
to open speculative hands here like say
I had ten nine suited I think while
normally I wouldn't consider opening
tonight suited here as it still it's a
huge disincentive to steal here with ten
nine suited when someone like his ARB is
an can just pick up you know even a hand
as because like ace Jack suited in or
East Jack offsuit and go all in and be
are ten nine students so what I mean
East Jack is more than good enough to
still raise here and we unfortunately
run into these King okay so the next
thing we get these Jack again and the
same guy who just doubled up through us
goes all-in and here I call him because
here the even though there's more chips
the positions are a lot later and
specifically and they went all-in for 14
big blinds when no one else was in the
pot so their range is you know their
range isn't super duper wide but it's
definitely wide enough that ace Jack I'm
happy to call here as far as what my
range is I think I think I wouldn't call
it East 10 off suit but I would call the
Beast 10 suited so probably ace 10
suited and I think I'd call the king
queen suited but not King Queen off suit
and the smallest hair I get it in with
is probably pocket sixes I think maybe
pocket
yeah probably pocket fives is to Lucy I
probably pocket sixes so we call so
unfortunately we lose to King ten suited
so he doubles up to us again
we're kind of short now yeah on that
last hand why go all on yourself why not
just call it going okay good question
yeah so yeah this is a good question so
in this case the two plays I'd say are
fairly close to acquittal because okay
so what's the difference right they're
gonna be the same most as almost always
because days is just gonna fall right
okay so what's the difference the
difference is if we don't go on then
check raise if let's say he picks up
aces right and then you can just go
all-in and we're basically forced to
call them because we can't if we put in
four four thousand one hundred and
eighteen and they go all and we can't
really fold for only three thousand or
we can't really fold preflop with 41
odds would that change if you're the big
stack it's like you X check raise a
stack and oh yeah for sure yeah yeah
that's a very good point yeah yeah for
sure so if we had the same stack as
chapter easier I would just call and
then as check-raise goes on and I would
probably fold okay but I mean I'm also
gonna call here with pocket aces so they
can't just look down that pocket twos
and go all-in and bully me around yeah
so so my strategy if we had their stack
would be do would be to call my entire
range and I plan on a plane but in this
case the only thing calling does is it
gives him more options like let's say
they had a very marginal situation like
let's say they had king queen suited
yeah I think if I if I only called they
could maybe RV for calling themself with
king queen suited I'm seeing a flop
whereas if I go all and I think they're
forced to fold Kingdom if you have a
better chance of making him exactly yeah
I'm just giving him fewer options but
it's very very marginally like it
affects it affects it basically
specifically for maybe king queen suited
like it affects basically for one hand
or maybe like two but you might as well
minimize the options you give your
opponent so yeah like I'd say the the
minimum stack size I would need before I
call instead of going with is maybe I
think maybe like 13,000 yeah I think at
13,000 it's sort of more than I'd wanna
risk
sure yeah okay so now we're kind of
short so we blind down for a bit we
don't get cards and when you don't get
cards in a tournament there's not really
much you can do other than lying down
not like snow all in with crap and just
lose so we blind down for a bit but
we're fortunate to pick up Kings so this
is sort of a no-brainer we go all and
there's no point trapping because
they're guaranteed to call us and we get
called by ace five and we win
which is good okay so the next hand we
get eight seven off suit and against a
button race I think calling is fine I
think their range is just going to be
wide enough where even though the
reverse implied odds once again really
don't work in our favor we just have to
sort of realize that equity from four
and a half to one odds so I'm gonna call
and so we fought nothing I'm planning me
just check fold so I check they check
back turn is a four once again we have
nothing I couldn't Bluff here but I
figure you know I'm not really looking
to make a big Bluff with this hand cuz I
have no draw no pair there's no point
but I will probably look to make a bluff
on the river if they also check just
because I whenever you have like no
chance of winning the pot then and it's
the river then making a bluff is not
unreasonable but in this case bluffing
is kind of bad because with any club
they might just call me because any club
is gonna have some equity so so I check
they check back the river is a fourth
Club which is I think a pretty good card
for me because you know I can easily
represent a small club and if I did have
a small club I am definitely not betting
so you know it's a pretty good current
for me to buff and they're probably
gonna have to fold Qinghai so so I bet
and I don't think I'd be better a big
you know I'm just looking for a size
where they have to fold sometimes and
they'll have to pay me off sometimes
when I have to have us want to have a
small club and so they raise me here
which is
which is pretty weird I don't really I
still don't really have a good idea of
what I think he has
I mean I'm certain they haven't made
beat you know sorry I just felt like you
know we could think a bit about doing
something crazy like go all in but they
were just weird I think it's unnecessary
you know we've got nothing so I just
bawled yeah I don't really know maybe
they just had like a slow play flush
impossible they have like a king high
flush here and they slow played the flop
they decided to still play the term
again because the term sore didn't hit
anybody yeah I'm not sure so so I pulled
here I mean it's possible they just had
a high club but I feel like with a high
club they should have been at some point
to sort of just because the a good flush
draw is just has enough equity but
nonetheless I guess we'll never know
that's one benefit of calling you can
find out what your opponent had okay so
the next time we had a queen Jack we've
got 12 bets I just go all-in 12 is
around the cutoff of right like I said
12 is sort of the cutoff where if you
have 12 bets or less instead of raising
just go all-in and that's what we do so
we get called but so this is actually a
pretty sick boy yeah so they flock to
bullnose but we've ever to hire full
house
it was yeah it's sort of a waste because
you know normally if this happens you
could win like a hundred big blinds from
them probably but instead we only won
how many eight big blinds so it's sort
of a waste but whatever okay so the next
hand
I got pocket fives and we've raised to
be variously a thousand and Liam kid
goes on and again and you know it's
irritating but I think once again I have
to fold it's I think I'm just I don't
have enough equity to call given his
range once again it's a situation where
it's a fairly big all in so you know I
could maybe not put them on aces
although given that they've done this
once they're more likely to just do this
with their entire range and play a
strategy where they're just going on
preflop a lot so maybe they could have
aces in their range but nonetheless
regardless I think it's not even that
close
potential yeah we don't really want to
call in frustration because you saw what
happened to the guy with pocket sevens
when demand of you are pocket jacks in
the earlier hand okay so I'll take a
short break there and then I'll finish
up the rest of the hands in like two
minutes okay so okay I'm gonna get
started okay so so okay so the next time
you get it we get King in a dog suit and
once again it's one of these situations
where you know we're not thrilled to be
calling especially now that our odds are
even a bit worse because they actually
made it 2.25 X actually a bit more like
0.35 X instead of 2x so against
degenerated but King off suit to big
cards I think with when we're sort of
not that deep the reverse implied odds
don't work against us that much so so we
call and so we check kids at once again
I'm checking my entire range that's how
I choose to play my strategy and they
bet and so this is sort of I think I
think this is a somewhat close situation
because I think there are
some drawers right there is a flush draw
and there are a bunch of straight jaws
if you if someone has Jack 10 or a queen
Jack or acquaintance so I do think there
is a decent amount of incentive to just
check raise all right so in the second
lecture I showed you a bunch of examples
where on boards like this you can check
for a zone with your good hands and
check resolve them with your drawers and
it's a pretty balanced strategy because
when you have a good hand you have a
good hand and when you have a draw you
have lots of outs when you get called
but in this and another advantage of
going all-in is let's say I'd like
Popeye let's say I had like 10 9 I would
probably want to be raising because
there's 10 9 even though we have a
pretty good hand
we kind of sort of want to protect our
hand right we don't really want a
jacquard clean or NH to come that much
so it's close but but in the end I
decided to call and I think and I think
I decided I'm just gonna play pretty
close pretty much I'm in my entire
strategy I'm just gonna call here as
tempting as it is like let's say I had I
had ace two diamonds or let's say like
Queen six and diamonds to checkers on I
think it's a board where you know it's
already paired and if I have a flush
draw I still have lots of opportunities
to Bluff on the river and if I have a
good hand there's not that many outs and
especially when I have it came so I'm
just gonna call and hope that the board
comes out well which I guess it does so
so I check again because this is how I'm
playing Jack n this is how I'm doing all
my hands essentially so they check back
the river is kind of bad for us but I
think it's hard for them to have a king
at this point so I just bet oh about a
bit more than half a pot maybe 60% of
pot yes 60% and and then okay so they
actually called me with 87 which i think
is pretty reasonable like i think e 7 is
a fine call against my strategy because
I could have easily had jack 10 or queen
10 or queen Jack here although I
probably also play a 9 the same way so
they are also paying off my nines and so
one good thing actually so this is one
interesting thing to think about that's
a sort of advance but I think it's cool
is
that they have h7 I think makes their
call a lot better than if they had say a
Stan or ace Jack and the reason for the
so even though h7 is in some sense of
worse hand than a standard ace Jack
they're the same on this board and I
think it's a the problem with ace 10 and
ace Jack is if they have a 10 or a jack
it's less likely I have a 10 or a jack
so you know because when they're calling
with a 7 essentially what they're hoping
for is hoping for me to have jack 10 or
queen 10 or queen Jack so if they have a
pretender or Jack it just decreases that
chance so it's almost like a 7 is a
better hand to call with an ace Jack so
but nonetheless you know with any ace I
think calling here is reasonable because
I do have plenty of Bluffs any miss
straight draw and you miss wash draw it
will Bluff in the same way on this river
okay so the next hand
so we yeah we run a bunch of pots which
is nice so we built our stack up so we
got pocket fours here and this guy
raises it to 1200 pocket fours is
definitely a hand where I want to be
Bluff re-raising with so I'm not you
know I'm not hoping to get called when I
rebase here but it's a hand that does
quite well against the range of hands I
get called by because a lot of times
it'll just be a skinny screen and and
and they will fold quite a large percent
of the time so I definitely want to
raise the only question is how do I
raise right I could just go all-in which
has the benefit that they can't call and
try to hit a pair because that would
actually be bad like let's say I made it
let's say I only leave 83,000 here it's
actually kind of bad if this guy calls
with this Queen Jack trying to hit a
pair because that's actually the best
strategy that they're basically they're
obvious strategy is good against my hand
so I want to either go all-in which sort
of denies them that opportunity or or I
could but the problem going all-in is
let's suppose check-raise picks up a
hand right then I'm going to be losing
the five pocket fours so you know there
is this delicate balance here and this
is why this is what I think tournaments
are interesting because you know there's
plays that are good against big stacks
and plays that are good against small
stacks but in reality and a tournament
there's going to be big stacks and small
stacks at the table and often you do
have to compromise between the less
two evils and that's sort of what I do
here so I decide to raise these
thirty-six hundred which is bigger than
I usually make it usually I make it
maybe like three thousand but when this
guy is this short ruffle low high I
don't really want to let them just call
but on the other hand I want to be able
to fold if one of these two guys check
razor vamps and picks up a hand so I
sort of compromise between making it
thirty six hundred they both fold and
this guy also folds which is I guess an
ideal result okay the next saying we
have a million offsuit and we make it
sixteen hundred so I know I've said make
it 2.25 X and I stand by that I think
that's a good strategy I think at the
time I'm just so once again I'm probably
still playing a lot of tables and I'm
kind of lazy so I'm too lazy to type in
like 1800 manually whereas the software
defaults to just 2x so I tend to just 2x
but I think it's probably not this
theoretical optimal strategy I would
guess that the optimal thing to do is
closer to 2.25 X so Babson calls us in
position and you know so immediately I
could think of it like what is their
range because it's a spot where I expect
them to go all-in with most of their
good hands so the question is you know
are they trapping me or do they
literally just always have a hand like
Jack ten suited king queen or something
like that so so immediately it's it's
sort of an interesting business spot
because I expect them to mostly be
raising when they want to play their
hands okay so we flopped for ten nine
and it's definitely a pretty bad board
for us overall like I think you know if
like regardless of their strategy like
if their strategy is to trap us
sometimes then this in this board is
just terrible and even if they're sandy
isn't
Travis they've always got a straight
drawn on this board because they're
gonna have king queen or queen Jack or
something so I think objectively it's a
pretty bad board maybe they do have ace
Jack Cory's between them self although
ace queen I think there is definitely
amazing preflop so probably just aced
Jack so I do think we're not in great
shape here but I decide to bet
anyway essentially just banking on my
ace of clubs I I definitely wouldn't be
betting this without the ace of clubs
but my strategy is to bet and if I get
called I'm gonna go all in on any Club
turn any Jack queen or Eastern so
essentially any club turn I have the nut
flush draw any Jack turn I have a good I
have a good straight job of two over
cards and any Queen or Eastern I gives
his right hand so I just think there's
enough trends where I can basically
continue bluffing continue barreling on
that one barrel has to be okay but I'm
only making this play because I have a
stick clubs like I think even with the
queen of clubs I probably would have
just given up this hand but will you get
a fold so I guess they probably had a
stack that's probably their most likely
hand maybe something like pocket sevens
they fold this yeah so that sort of
shows you the importance sometimes a
back door draws because like let's say
they had pocket sevens here like let's
say they called with pocket sevens which
I don't think is unreasonable if I
didn't have the ace of clubs I'm gonna
just have to end up giving up on a bunch
of turns and they would take down the
pot with their pocket sevens but because
I have these so clubs it's just very
very unlikely they end up winning the
hand with the pair of sevens because I'm
gonna shove a lot of turns and they're
just gonna have to fold okay so the next
thing we get queen Jack again and we
base here and so the same guy dancing
they call and we get a good plus so so I
bet okay so I'm gonna hug her like this
yeah so I bet 1600 here which is quite
small it's like 40% it's like less than
40% of five I might have done it out of
laziness but or I might have just done
it because of my cards because I have
two pair and I'm trying to suffer and
and put it on his money slowly but
looking back I definitely don't think
this is how I want to be playing my
entire strategy on this block like I
think I want to be betting at least half
the pot when there's a flush draw a
straight draw like a bunch of straight
draws I definitely think this bet is way
too small it's just on average even if I
even if have a pretty good hand let's
say like Queen nine there's just a lot
of bad cards for me that I don't want to
be betting this small on this board so I
don't know if at the time I just like
misclicked and messed up or I was lazy
and I just wanted to make it to X or I
specifically had to read that I could
exploit this player by betting small but
this is not a balance this is not how I
would like to balance my strategy and if
you ever see me doing this most likely I
had a really good hand as I do in this
case so unfortunately it doesn't work
but so I'm gonna talk about this a bit
more so I'm gonna jump back to theory
just for a bit so I'm gonna [ __ ] it I
don't think I've talked about this
before but I want to say that bet sizing
depends on board texture so let me
explain what I mean here so essentially
there's two types of boards there's dry
boards and drawing boards so I hate this
terminology because either two words
that mean opposite things and they sound
very similar especially if you don't end
up see but it's dry and dry okay so dry
boards is basically boards where the
winner is mostly decided by before the
river and you're either way ahead or way
behind drawing boards is basically
boards with a lot of wash draw straight
draws where every subsequent cards card
can change the board a lot and it's hard
to fold because all hands on equity
so in reality most boards you know
there's somewhere in between it's a
spectrum but okay so what are some
characteristics of dry boards well a
board tends to be dry if it's pattern
like 4 or 4 & 8 that tends to be pretty
dry cuz not much is going in it most
you'll have a mist at board a board is
dry if the highest card is big like if
the highest card is an ace then against
someone with an ace if you don't have a
place flush or straight draw you're
already kind of drawing close to dead
whereas you know if the highest card is
a 10 then if you have a queen you always
have an opportunity to turn the Queen
and beat them it's Drive there's no
middle cards for straight draws if
there's no flush draws or I'd say if
there's already four to a flush or are
to four to a straight then it's also
sort of dry because like if there's
already four diamonds and it's also sort
of decided to when it's already like if
you have a big diamond Judaism pretty
much guaranteed to win borrowing some
full house
same with floor to a street if it's like
nine ten Jack Queen if you have a king
you're just pretty much guaranteed doing
and so on the other hand what are dry
boards is it sort of the opposite right
small cards why small cards because
everyone's gonna have over cards which
is six outs flush draws or three dual
flush is also very dry because if
there's three to a flush then someone
with just an any card of that suit has a
flush draw more straight draws so how
should your play change on these two
types of boards well on dry boards you
can bet pretty small fractions of the
pot on the flop in turn and your
opponent might not have the odds to call
so like you know if the flop is ace ace
two or maybe a say seven with no flush
draws you can bet like a fifth of the
pot and your opponent is still gonna
have to fold a lot of their hands
because if you've got an ace they're
just way behind
what's another characteristic is any
draw might be good enough to make it
Bluff so like if the board is a a7 with
no flush draw and you've got like eight
nine with a backdoor flush draw that's a
pretty good hand to make the bluff
because you've got you've got three
years straight in through your flush
which is sort of the most you could
possibly ask for on that flop with
respect to drugs and another aspect of
playing dry boards is sort of slow
playing tricky plays are good because
the thing that matters isn't preventing
your opponent from seeing the tournament
river and not letting them see oats the
thing that matters is sort of convincing
your opponent of that you have a good
hand when you don't or
convincing them that you don't have a
good hand when you do so it's all about
tricking your opponent disguising these
tricky I mean touching say that it's not
all the like simple play can still be
good on dry boards but in general slow
playing is reasonable and tricking
trying to trick your opponent is is more
important wears on drawing boards you
know you just have bet large fractions
the pot before the river because every
hand has so many outs you really don't
want to be giving them good odds to call
and on the flop in turn if you don't
have anything then just don't put
anybody because bluffing is pretty moot
because so many hands aren't folding
because they have votes and ya don't
really Sol play if you have a good hand
similarly just put all the money in
right away because they're gonna call
very often because they're always gonna
have some notes so that's roughly how
how the play changes okay so okay so
I'll come back to this we'll see these
hands in a bit so coming back to this
queen jack hand the reason why I think
my bet is two stalls because I would
consider this Queen Jack's three with a
flush draw to be a fairly drawing board
fairly close to the draw end of the
spectrum and for that and I said you
know you have to bet big fractions of
the pot and Here I am betting close to a
third of the pot on the flop so I think
it does not a good strategy but I take
the bunt down okay so the next hand we
have East Queen offsuit and so this guy
calls and so my rule was roughly you
know raise it to 3x plus 1 so 3 you
count how many flippers there are before
you and you add 3 to that and you
multiply that by the big blind is
roughly while you raise it to so in this
case 4,000 I make it 40 to 50 if they
decide to do some weird look Fraze by
the way like if they go all-in here I'm
definitely calling I'm just not gonna
believe them and ace queen offsuit is
definitely good enough so they just call
which is a bit weird considering their
odds aren't that good and they're out of
position but we flopped three Hudson we
have the Queen of Hearts and in this
situation I'm just betting I'm just
betting pretty big into the pot so I
considered this would be a fairly dryly
flop so I
that big and so even though I'm in
position so position is sort of an
incentive it maybe bets smaller because
you have position on later Suites and
you can control the betting better on
later streets
but so this is a fairly big bet
considering I'm in position but I'm just
happy to get it in here so contrast this
with an earlier hand I think I also had
East Queen except it was only I only had
three to a flush and I said it was very
important that I had the ace of the suit
but here it's just very hard for me to
be in terrible shape
you know like in theory they could have
I suppose ace 9 with the ace of hearts
like that hand would be crushing me
because I would be drawing to literally
three outs to care my queen but it's
just there's not that many combinations
because it would involve an off suit
hand which they're way less likely to
have when they call me out in position
or it would involve a hand like pocket
kings with the King of Hearts which is
also pretty unlikely because they
probably would have done some raising
preflop so I just think no matter what
they have I'm gonna be in great shape
here and I just have more than enough
votes to just game ball and so they pull
okay the next thing we have Queen 10 off
so I open from under the gun I think
it's fine you know it looks a bit loose
and it is but I think in terms of
raising some smaller cards to balance it
so that I will sometimes have smaller
cards in my hand you know you can't
really ask for more than a student
connector so Queen 10 so did I raise
from under the gun and the big volume
calls when their own family start the
hand being 18 that's deep so we flop to
210 and I think so this is a good
example of I think a very dry board
where there's really not much going on
and it is possible they have a deuce but
just in general there's no straight
draws and no flush draws I guess there
are some over cards but still it's
pretty close to as as try as you can get
yeah and they checked me in I've at 2000
which i think is actually too big here
like to be honest I don't think I needed
you
this much I mean I have a good hand but
you know if I had if I didn't have a
pair I only want to be betting like 1500
I think that's a fine size I think
spending 1,500 is more than enough on
this board just because there's really
nothing going on and but I guess I was
lazy I bet 2,000 and and they call so so
yeah so this is the this so as you can
see there's a huge difference between my
flatbed sizing depending on the texture
of the board and that's sort of what I
want to do Drive that's the point I want
you to drive across through some of
these examples so they call me so we
turn a six and they just a check I'm
just going to keep it simple and bet I'm
not going to try anything tricky and
obviously I'm not folding with top pair
and a flush draw so they go all in I
call so we prefer a flush and a turned
out to actually be necessary is they had
a deuce um so it is possible here I
think for then you have a deuce you know
I think their plate the flop is is a bit
loose with two nine suited but not
completely terrible because with four
point five to one odds nothing is really
that terrible but I guess yeah we got
lucky but I do think that call is a bit
marginal because we are under the gun so
you know our range is fairly strong so
that's a nice pocket win so we're a
fairly big stack now I guess for chip
leader at the table and check-raise min
raises from there and we have pocket
deuces
I think definitely our hands too weak to
go all-in with as a bluff against and
under they got an opening range so the
only options really are call or fold
basically our hand does have terrible
and reverse implied odds post flop
though so I think you know I think if
you wanted to fold here it wouldn't be
terrible but I guess I think calling is
fine to with four point five to one and
also you know in some sense you do have
odds to set mine here I think because
because so the chances of hitting a
third deuce on the flop is about one and
eight so my odds are only four point
five to one but there are implied odds
in the case I do it is
so like literally if my strategy is call
and fold unless the pop is a 2 on it I
don't think I'm losing a ton of money
there and you know if there ever is a
case where I where they check down and I
get to take them on with you just a pair
of two's then I'm just printing money by
calling so so I decide to call the flop
is the flop I'm dozen have a two so it's
bad but you know how do the flops that
don't have a two it's probably not that
bad considering this the three and seven
is not that likely to pair when he's
under the gun but nonetheless I fold
you know like if I could do the cheat I
talked about where I could disconnect
and call and see the river I definitely
would but you know if I call I have to
decide again on the term right of the
call I decided get on the river whether
to call and it's just not going to be a
good situation even though for this
immediate bet I think I definitely have
odds to call with a backdoor flush draw
and often they're just gonna have a
skein but it's just impossible to play
the hand in this sort of just
demonstrates you know why it's very
risky when you decide to play a hand
like pocket deuces out of position
because it's very easy to get roped in
right like let's say I call here and
then I called the flop thinking they
might have a skein they bet small so I
have good odds and I have a backdoor
flush draw so let's say I call and then
the turn is like the five of clubs or
something and then they bet like 40% of
pot well like am I gonna talk myself
into a call again
maybe these now I hit a third clubs but
if I do then if the river something
random I do so it's just all these
decisions that I'm not going to be able
to make well whether it's for my
opponent it's going to be fairly easy
they're gonna just Bluff they're bad
hands value bet they're good hands and
check down the hands in the middle which
beat me okay so the next hand we get ace
king off suit and we raise and the big
blind calls flop is nine to seven so
note that the big blind just come move
to the table and they actually cover us
so so they're they're probably one of
the biggest acts in the tournament um so
they check to us I decided to check it
back here which I don't think it's
terrible but I think it's a bit of a
scared play that I
I think I would have rather saw myself
bet you know if it was shallower like
let's say we only had 20,000 chips then
I think just checking is good because if
I bet they're probably going to be check
raising with a lot of their flush draws
straight draws and then like pairs of
nines or pairs of sevens and I'm gonna
have to fold with a pretty good hand
we're too good over cards and a backdoor
flush draw
but when it's this deep you know they
really can't just check raisin nine
because they're gonna have to be worried
about pocket aces on our part so so I
think it's we're not gonna get chapter
is that often and by betting we just
make the pot bigger when we do hit a
king or an ace and also make it more
likely that we can Bluff them off a nine
or a seven by the river so I would like
to see myself back but I don't think
checking is terrible by the argument
that I will most of the time you know
I'm by betting I am folding out
basically all the hands that I'd be and
keeping all the hands that beat me so
it's close but I would like to see
myself bet but as played you know if I'm
gonna check the flop I'm not going to
bet this turn because the whole point of
betting the flop is so that I could
potentially bet the turn and got the
river and get him before a pair of nines
or a pair of sevens but by now I'm not
gonna really have any hope of giving him
before the nine and I'm just gonna try
to pin the pot with my East King high
and so I just check it down the river
check I think is very very obvious
because I'm literally only getting
called by better hands if I bet the
river so this is a of Queen ten I think
they probably should have bluffed the
river
I think Queen 10 is weak enough where
there's very rarely winning the pot with
Queen 10 high that they basically need
ooh bluff and then put me to a decision
but nice to win that okay the next thing
we have Jack kind so not too exciting so
this saying got you to down the button
raises from the button and we call and
we flop nothing so the best thing to do
is Bluff off all your chips but no I
just bought
okay so the next thing it's also a guys
this has got a garlicky do you so where
I should apply so the two big sacks at
the table are actually playing a lot of
hands against each other um I just call
here with Jax I think I don't think it
would be terrible to just raising that
at all but I think it's it's it is sort
of unnecessarily risky like I think I
think it wouldn't be it wouldn't be a
terrible play to just raise and get it
all in but it's definitely thin like
you're not printing value by raising and
getting it all in because if they
rebates all in their ranges and look
pretty strong and pocket jacks is not
really crushing them so I think we need
to have cleans or better to really be
hoping to get it on against this guy
here so with Jax I just call and also
you know this protects my calling range
of it like let's say let's say like
check-raise things I'm weak and decides
to make the play here and they rear A's
to like 10,000 then garlicky DD folds I
can come back around and go all-in and
sort of Surprise them so it does protect
my calling range a bit as well I call we
get a 965 flop they check in I bet and I
think betting is a fairly natural play
you know I don't want to give East King
outs and I just want to win the pot
right now but I was thinking to myself
after that you know if they check
released here that's really a gross spot
I actually I I would hate my life if
they checked right because I literally
don't know what I should do
it's in one on one hand I would you know
I would be inclined befall because it's
kind of weird for them to want to check
raise me here I think without having it
without having like a bigger pair or a
flush draw with lots of outs but at the
same time it's just you know why would
they check pocket aces to me here maybe
we do try to trap me so it would have
been a really gross spot I think if I
got check raised and by that argument I
think against a very tricky player if
you could be check raising here as a
trap and as a bluff with a balanced
strategy I may be checking is better
than just to protect myself from that
but I think against him
reasonably confident nothing crazy was
going to happen and yet so they just
both okay so think it's this guy yes I
guess we're playing a lot of pots
against the same player I think it's
getting fairly late in the tournament at
this point it's not a huge tournament
maybe like 80 90 players and it's
probably down to like 20 25 at this
point so they raise we call with P Nate
off we're a bit deep here so our reverse
and fly dogs are actually sort of bad
but but we decide we call and we flop
two three five so I'm just gonna fold
here but they decide to check and then
we turn a flush draw but I'm still just
gonna check and basically that pretty
much every River maybe not a deep river
but so we river to six and I essentially
bet as a bluff because our hand has no
hope of winning if if it gets a showdown
and and it works this time so yes so
yeah we played a lot of pots against
them and it seems like they are fairly
willing to just check and fold their
hands so I'm not too aggressive so I
guess one thing to keep in mind is maybe
we should get out of the way if we do
see them raising okay so this situation
is similar to the situation the very
first hand we discussed where we had
king queen and we had roughly 30 big
blinds and I talked sort of about the
benefits of raising versus calling it's
pretty much the exact same situation and
I decide you sort of raise essentially
as a bluff but also King Queen plays
pretty well when they do call on because
I'm always good when I hit talk there so
we make it eight thousand but
unfortunately this time this Gerard ox
goes all-in so we basically just have to
fold and the end for twenty eight
thousand is small enough where we can
just happily get away here and it
actually turns out this guy also goes on
which makes the decision even easier so
yeah it looks like we may have
pocket aces and pocket kings have tax
doesn't always wait when you revisit the
king queen all right so still the same
table we get East Jack absolute under
the gun we remade in this Garrard oxide
falls we thought King nine deuce with
two hearts and I think this is sort of
pretty much the worst sloppy one of the
worst flops I could get you know if
there if there was like two higher cards
like a king and a queen I would have a
gut shot straight draw and if it was all
little cards I'd have two over cards but
here there's a flush draw that I have no
part of and also they're somewhat likely
you have a king and if they do I only
have three outs and my aces so I'm just
going to give this up you know so I
talked about the power of continuation
betting before where continuation
betting is good because my range is
stronger than theirs I can have aces I
can Bluff etc and yeah in general
continuation betting being aggressive
especially when you're the preflop
aggressor is very good but I think this
is just one of the worst flops and I'm
just going to give up so I checked they
bet and I fold I mean I think sometimes
I will check a reasonably good hand here
to protect the time so you know so so
that they can't just bet here with any
two cards and know for sure awful but
most of the times I'm checking here I'm
gonna be fairly weak which is maybe
exploitable but I give up the hand so
8/5 suited I decided to call on this
online I know this goes against my
recommendation from the first class I
think calling from the small blind is
actually both theoretically and
practically a pretty good strategy for a
lot of cases but it's a bit complicated
because you have to sometimes like you
have you sometimes limp raised as a
bluff you have to sometimes look praise
and trap with aces so it's a bit
complicated so I just said for
simplicity you have to be should just
raise your fold which is still
reasonable I think but I decide to call
here and it's checked we get a pretty
good flop for our hand but probably a
better flop for his range because what
we call were less likely you have really
small cards than he does but I mean we
have a good spot for a hand so
I am still gonna bet my pants so I bet I
bet half pot which is maybe not big
enough to be honest considered in town
draw the board is and we got a call we
turn a nine which is a great card
because it gives not only does it
complete our hand there's a lot of
drawers out there and I met quite a bit
here so this is where I was talking
about if the board is dry you need a bit
big and not give your opponent odds so I
bet six eight eight into ten eight
hundred the reason for the eights is
because it's easier to type like six
eight eight eight ten six eight zero
zero so you'll see that quite a lot and
we get called yeah and another sometimes
you can get more creative you can do
like one two three four five six seven
that's like a popular bet because you
can just slide your finger across the
keyboard yeah there's a lot of weird
idiosyncrasies but I think so that 15
555 here and he folds and yeah so I mean
I'm playing I'm playing like this with
my missed speed draw as I missed heart
draws and unfortunately we don't get
paid off okay so Jack eight suited here
the small blind raises definitely I'm
gonna call and we flop top here they bet
and so I think this is so this is a spot
where you know I think my hand is
there's benefits of raising and benefits
of calling and overall I decided the
benefits of raising were higher so I
decided to raise and just get it all in
although I think calling is not
unreasonable because your hand sort of
isn't good enough where you're just like
really really happy to get it on I mean
it's good enough where I'm gonna get it
on but I'm not like thrilled if they go
all-in and I have to call so that's one
disadvantage of getting it on but I just
think compared to the advantage of you
know not giving them a chance to to
sakyo me and beat me in the hand is a
pretty big advantage you know not
letting a queen king or ace roll off
another advantage of calling is being
able to pick off Bluffs but I just think
in this flop I want to play a strategy
where I'm gonna raise to a small size
and
to the decision both with my top hairs
like Jax and also my hands like 7 9 or
whatever so I decided race but I think
calling would have been fun and people
the next and we have HK night so we got
like seven more hands yes I'll I'll go a
bit quickly near the end but I think
we'll get through all the hands
this hand is fairly easy they make it
5,000 and we have ace king and we just
go all in
there's no point soul playing
essentially especially when you know
they have Jack ten they have lots of
those so we go on and they fold so it is
a bit curious here because they actually
only had 12 big blinds here so they
could have just went all-in themself but
they decided to raise small so that they
could fold if someone behind picks up a
monster and I guess they were paid off
this time but yeah like for this hand
like one disadvantage of their plate
right I suppose we had king two suited
we would have folded if they went all-in
but now we can call and see it flop so
but it but for the because we had aced
King then I guess they profited from not
committing their whole stack okay we
have King Jack offsuit we make it six
thousand and this guy goes all-in
I fold here I think it's not that close
I think with King Jack suited it's close
but I'd still fold this King Jack suited
I'd probably call with East Jack offsuit
plus I would probably call it a Sten
suited and I'd call with king queen
suited and probably King Queen off suit
as well in this case and so in the last
class I said being stupid is very
important when you're behind but when
you're potentially ahead just having a
slightly better hand is very important
so I think in this situation I would
fold King Jack suited but call the King
Queen off suit because a decent part of
his range is hands like King Jack and
king queen so here at king queen and
degenerated so far so good I love making
this play with king queen um it's
actually not that unfounded
good hand bluff with that at the same
time sort of protects your range in the
case that he calls and also your hand
doesn't play that well if you just call
because you're not suited so it's it
really is King I mean in this tournament
we happen to God we've happened to been
dealt King Queen a lot and gone into
situations where we can be based lot of
people but it really is my favorite hand
to do this with so it might be even be
too predictable because I just always
have King whatever I do this but we do
take it down here east Jack offsuit this
guy so this degenerated guy who we just
read at this point is probably late
after the tournament I am paying
attention and I am aware that I just
really raised this guy three hands
earlier so they make a big race here to
nine thousand and I call with a strap
which I regret quite a bit I think I
think it's just too weak a hand to play
and if I'm gonna play it I think I
should just go all-in and try to win the
hand preflop this is even though I'm in
position I think it's just gonna be hard
to play you know even when I hit an ace
or a jack I'm still gonna quite often be
behind and if I don't hit any thorough
Jack I'm pretty much always just gonna
have to fold and that's basically what
happens so I don't know why I just gave
away night that was it chips there but
okay so Queen Jack suited I just go
all-in from the small blind because it's
so even though we have 15 big blinds
which is more than twelve I said last
class at from the small blind you're
really really really incentivized to go
all-in because if you don't then the
other guy has position where is like
from the button if you just raise the
big blind calls you have position so I
go all-in
putting Jack suited is more than good
enough and we and the next hand okay so
this is actually great illustration the
very next thing we get Queen Jack off
and we just raise from this button and
it's exactly the reason I said because
we have position so we don't mind if the
pot gets plugged post flop so the small
boy goes all in and no note that there
are
fairly short here they only have 14 big
blinds to start the hand so I would have
easily called with Queen Jack suited
even with Queen Jack off I'm not certain
that folding is a better play than
calling it's just your odds are
basically good enough here and their
range will be fairly loose when I Basin
the buttons because they're gonna think
I don't have much when I raise from the
button so it's quite possible calling
here would have been the right play it's
very close I think I would have
definitely called with East 9 offsuit I
would have definitely called with King
10 off suit yeah it's pretty close I
decided to fold maybe I also knew that
they were kind of tight normally when I
play but I'm not showing here is I have
like statistics on every player of like
overall the hands what percent of the
time they raise what percent they folded
so I have a rough idea while I'm playing
of how tight everyone is and maybe I
just knew he was tight actually let me
see if I can turn it back on here yeah
let me see that might be why so so at
this okay so these numbers actually it's
fairly loose yeah actually I'm not sure
why folded so this 10.7 is the raised
percentage and what this says is ten
point seven percent of the time he could
re-raise he'd be raised it's only over a
sample of 187 hands but it's it's
audited yeah I think it's definitely
looser than average um although it's a
bit biased because we're playing out a
five handed table nonetheless it's close
I think calling probably would have been
okay but I fold it let me turn this off
it's quite annoying okay so so this is
near the final table now this is I think
the second final table there's maybe
like 11 or 12 left and I'm just going to
show you the final hands before the
final table so this hand is a no-brainer
when we go all in and fortunately we
hold against pocket twos so okay so the
the very last hand also fairly
no-brainer this guy goes on so yeah
poker is easy if you just get the pocket
jacks are theses all the time
so we win this one okay so this is the
last name before the final table so in a
future class not the Friday class
because Jennifer Shehadeh is speaking
but in a future
I'll go through the final table and I'll
maybe also goes through all the hands
and opportun for the hands where I got
in a big pot so let me just quickly go
back to this slides right so so I really
only talked about two concepts in this
class it was this draw draw versus dry
boards so try to remember that while you
guys are playing then changing your
about sizing depending on the board
pressure and also this preflop would be
raising strategy even though I didn't
give you a conclusion here on what your
ease with I shouldn't give you some
rough guidelines and the advantages and
disadvantages of each flight and yeah
okay cool
so that's it come on Friday's class it
should be it should be really exciting
Jennifer Shehadeh she'll break a bit
about chest as well but I'll convince
her not to talk too much about chess
will remind but thanks guys